SOMETHING ELSE. WE WERE,
THOSE TO DO IN THIS SEGMENT,
WE HAVEN'T DONE YET THIS
CONCEPT OF RECEIVERS WHO MAKE
THE QUARTERBACK BECAUSE WITH
DAVANTE ADAMS. YES HE'S VERY
GOOD BUT THE QUARTERBACK
MAKES THE RECEIVER BEFORE WE
FINALLY PULL THE PLUG ON THIS
SEGMENT ARE THEIR NAMES THAT
COME TO MIND FOR YOU. MOO
TALK ABOUT JERRY RICE AND JOE
MONTANA. YESTERDAY DID RICE
MAKE MONTANA DID MONTANA MAKE
RICE WHO ARE THE RECEIVERS
THAT MAKE THE QUARTERBACKS?
AND THERE AREN'T A TON OF
THEM THAT YOU CAN POINT TO
AND SAY YOU COULD PUT ANY
QUARTERBACK ON THE FIELD AND
THIS GUY'S GOING TO BE GOOD
AND I MEAN, A LOT OF THE
TIMES IT WAS, YOU KNOW, LIKE
AGAIN. YEAH, I WOULD I SAY
IT'S MORE RICE THAN MONTANA.
YEAH, I WOULD. BUT IT WASN'T
LIKE MONTANA WITH SOME SLOUCH
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT. SO
ALL RIGHT, SO YEAH, YOU'RE
RIGHT. IT'S HARD. ACTUALLY,
WHEN YOU COME AT COME TO IT
THAT LIKE LIKE IN THE NFL
RIGHT NOW. I MEAN, IT'S HARD
TO FIND THAT GUY RIGHT NOW,
TALKED ABOUT LIKE A RECEIVER
THAT MAKES A QUARTERBACK,
ROBINSON IS PROBABLY THE GUY
THAT JUMPS OUT TO ME THE MOST,
HE'S LIKE HAD THOUSAND YARD
RECEIVING SEE RECEIVING
SEASONS WITH
YOU KNOW, DREW BISCAY AND
NICK FOLES AND ALL THESE
OTHER ISSUES. BUT LIKE
THROUGH TIME, I'M GONNA GO
TERRELL OWENS, HE'S ONE THAT
PROBABLY JUMPS OUT THERE,
RIGHT? FOR A GUY THAT MORE
TIMES THAN NOT MADE HIS
QUARTERBACK RATHER THAN THE
OTHER SIDE OTHER WAY AROUND.
I THINK YOUR MAN RANDY MOSS,
PROBABLY FITS THAT MOLD SOON,
RIGHT? I'LL GIVE HIM THE
YEARS WITH BRADY, HE'S
CARRYING THE SQUAD OR
WHEN HE WAS A ROOKIE IN 1998,
THERE WAS A SENSE THAT YOU
COULD PUT ANYONE OUT THERE
WHO WAS CAPABLE OF THROWING
THE BALL DOWN THE FIELD, AND
THAT GUY WOULD HAVE HAD A
GREAT SEASON. THEY STARTED
THE YEAR WITH BRAD JOHNSON
AND THEY SHOWED GREAT PROMISE
WEEK TO BRAD, JOHNSON BREAKS
A LEG INCOMES RANDALL.
CUNNINGHAM RANDALL,
CUNNINGHAM HAS A CAREER
REBIRTH. HE'D BEEN OUT OF
FOOTBALL TOGETHER IN 1996 WAS
BACK UP IN MINNESOTA IN 97-98.
HE'S AN MVP CANDIDATE. WHY?
BECAUSE HE KNEW TO LOOK OVER
AT RANDY MOSS, AND
RANDY MOSS WAS SINGLE COVERED.
HE DROPPED BACK AND HE YOU
KNOW, CRANK BACK THE CATAPULT
AND LET IT FLY AND MOSS WOULD
GO GET IT MOSS WAS THE
ULTIMATE AS LONG AS YOU HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO CAN GET THE BALL
IN THE AIR, RIGHT? HE'S GOING
TO MAKE YOU LOOK GOOD BECAUSE
HE'S GOT THE SPEED AND HE'S
GOT THE BALL SKILLS, THE BODY
CONTROL, THE ABILITY TO ADAPT
AND ADJUST TO THE BALL. ON
THE FLY WHERE HE'S JUST GOING
TO GO GET IT, NO MATTER WHERE
IT'S COMING DOWN. SO MOSS.
WAS THAT GUY? YEAH.
THROUGHOUT HIS VIKINGS TENURE
AND DAUNTE CULPEPPER
ULTIMATELY WAS THE
BENEFICIARY OF IT FROM
UNTIL HE WELL UNTIL MOSS LEFT
AFTER THE 2004 SEASON. BUT
YEAH, MOSS WITHOUT QUITE MOSS
TO ME, IS THE ULTIMATE
RECEIVER WHO MADE THE
QUARTERBACK? YEAH, HE'S, I
YOU MIGHT BE RIGHT. HE'S UP
THERE. I'LL GIVE YOU ANOTHER
ONE THAT I THINK IS A REAL
GOOD ONE THAT KIND OF LIKE
SLIPS THROUGH THE CRACKS,
EVERY NOW AND THEN ANDRE
JOHNSON, RIGHT? WITH THAT
COMBINATION WITH MATT SCHAUB
YOU KNOW AGAIN MATT SHOP HAD
A GREAT CAREER. I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE HIS CAREER. I'M JUST
SAYING, LIKE MAN, ANDRE
JOHNSON WAS A STUD. HE'S ONE
OF THE GREATEST OF ALL TIME.
HE DEFINITELY MADE MORE OF
THAT.
RELATIONSHIP THEN VICE VERSA.
THAT'S ANOTHER ONE THAT JUMPS
YOU KNOW, TIM BROWN OTHER
THAN HIS LIKE RICH GANNON
YEARS, I MEAN, WHO ELSE WAS
HE REALLY? YOU KNOW, HE WAS
NEVER A PART OF LIKE A REALLY
AWESOME MACHINE OFFENSE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. I'D SIT
THERE AND SAY HE COULD BE ONE
OF THOSE GUYS. YOU COULD KIND
OF, LIKE, THROW INTO THAT
CATEGORY THAT, HEY, HE COULD
INTO THAT CATEGORY THAT, HEY,
HE COULD GET OPEN AND KIND
OF MAKE A QUARTERBACK LOOK
GOOD, NO MATTER WHAT,
ESPECIALLY IN HIS PRIME. BUT
YEAH, THIS FEW AND FAR
BETWEEN STEVE LARGENT. HE
MIGHT EVEN FALL IN THAT
CATEGORY. YOU LOOK AT IT,
JUST TOP RECEIVERS ALL TIME.
YOU CAN REALLY STAPLE THOUGH,
HIS NAME RIGHT? OTHER THAN
YOU KNOW, THE OLD SORNE. YES
OR NO. EXACTLY THE RIGHT. I
WAS THINKING THE OLD LEFTY
COACH. I COULDN'T THINK OF
HIS NAME, RIGHT? RIGHT. HEY,
HEY, HOW ABOUT THIS THOUGH?
YEAH. HOW ABOUT THE GUY WHO
CAUGHT PASSES FROM MATT
SCHAUB, BRIAN, HOYER, TOM,
CASE KEENUM, TJ YATES RYAN
FITZPATRICK, BRANDON WEEDEN,
AJ MCCARRON, RYAN MALLETT
BROCK OSWEILER, AND FINALLY
DESHAUN WATSON. THAT'S HOW
ABOUT THE ANDRE HOP? OH, YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE RIGHT. YOU'RE
RIGHT. IT'S
THE OBVIOUS ONE, IT'S BECAUSE
WE HAVE RECENT MEMORY OF HIM
AND WATSON TOGETHER BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT THE REST OF THAT.
AIN'T THAT GOOD? HE WAS
MAKING THE OFFENSE AND THE
RECEIVER YOUR HE MIGHT BE THE
BIGGEST EXAMPLE OF RIGHT NOW.
HEY I'LL SAY ODELL EARLY IN
HIS CAREER IT WHAT HE WAS
DOING PRICE I'M SURPRISED YOU
KNOW HIS SONG FOR ODELL
BECKHAM JR. I'M SURPRISED. IT
TOOK YOU THIS LONG INTO THE
CONVERSATION TO MENTION HIM?
WELL, I KNOW IT HURTS HE
HASN'T PLAYED IN THE WHILE. I
MEAN I NEED HIM TO PLAY AND
THEN I'LL COME UP WITH A SONG
THAT'S
USUALLY HOW IT HAPPENS. I
WATCH HIGHLIGHTS AND I GET
HAPPY AND I START HUMMING
SONGS. AND THAT'S HOW I COME
TO THESE STUPID THINGS. I DO,
I DON'T KNOW. AND YEAH, COME
ON OBJ, I NEED YOU OUT THERE.
WELL, ODELL BECKHAM'S, GOTTEN
IT DONE WITH THE GIANTS, AND
WE SEEN FLASHES WITH THE
GIANTS, AND WE SEEN FLASHES
WITH THE BROWNS, AND IF HE
GETS HEALTHY, WE MAY SEE MORE
THAN FLASHES BECAUSE THAT TING
BETTER. WE
M